[Music]
hey YouTube thanks for finally getting
back to me so yeah I was just wondering
why all my videos getting D monetized
mm-hmm family for any content yeah I
mean I could do that if like me you can
keeping up with the current anomie
trends you may have noticed that
recently anime has gotten more and more
cultured why the hell are you here
teacher Mira types I want you to show me
your panties with a disgusted face it's
gotten to the point we start to question
wait is hentai more explicit anime or is
anime just safer work hentai so instead
of debating where the line starts and
ends I thought why not go straight to
the source and drag you all down to the
depths of depravity with me that's right
if you think you're milf Sakai Emoto
loving harem fanservice anime is weird
well welcome to hentai where
degeneracies but a word jail is just a
room shame is a lifestyle choice and
hell is only a tanning bed hi i'm Giga
can i have an innate fear of being
monetized yes this is your introduction
to the absolute peak culture fat teddy
samuel l.jackson approved world of
x-rated anime so come on down take a
seat and get ready to bask in the most
glorious media mankind has made cause
it's called hentai and it's art if
you're one of you who have yet to
experience this world spanish procedure
usually begins with sitting down hitting
ctrl shift m' and renouncing your faith
in god and a few one of the people who
don't know where hentai is no maolin
hentai hentai is brilliant yes it's a
sub-genre of japanese manga and anime
etc yeah let's just keep about that now
look I know even from my standards this
topic is pushing the boundary so to keep
ourselves safe on YouTube all mention of
genitalia will be replaced with
delicious fruit and will refer to the
explicit act of intercourse as fortnight
cuz remember boys and girls despite the
dark endless rabbit holes at hentai is
these are all works of fiction and
nobody likes it we just start playing
fortnight without asking for consent
alright hentai well the concept of a
lease has existed for almost as long as
human civilization but modern
incarnations have evolved this art form
to a point where Japan can have seven
different words to describe
his food sizes that you think to
yourself man why can't my language be
this cultured it is often speculated if
all anime fans watch hentai and with
good reason - because asking anime fans
if they watch hentai it's like asking
people if they've ever peed in the
shower everyone's done it at least once
but no one will admit it publicly I mean
I certainly haven't of course hentai
shouldn't be completely alien even to
those who don't watch anime in fact the
old Association people used to have with
hentai or even anime in general was of
course tentacles find any clip of
tentacles in it and the top comment is
guaranteed to be oh well I've seen
enough hentai to know where this is
going and the origin of this is often
associated with the famous painting the
dream of the fisherman's wife but the
modern incarnation of tentacles is
actually credited to Toshiro my ADA who
used them as a substitute for male
genitalia in order to skirt around
Japanese censorship laws for explicit
material in a rare documented case of a
human being using a hundred percent of
their brain because somehow it [__]
worked but that's not the only piece of
hemp either spends browsing hours in pop
culture here and there as if you've been
hanging around on the internet you may
have seen this facial expression that
hurts my heart a blushing girl with her
eyes rolled up tongue sticking out with
the occasional or this is a hey gal and
while still a staple of hentai it is now
more often known as a viable career path
girls can take online or wearable peril
ship posters used to be able to identify
their own kind in a public setting but
really this only scratches the surface
of the wide ocean of the generous sea
because it is a medium that appeals to
anything anything and part of the fun is
discovering a very specific fetish you
never knew you had but on the inverse
this is countered by losing your faith
in humanity seeing some of the fetishes
other people have for the most part the
types of stories you get isn't so much
different from what you find in other
high-class well written erotica I see
you don't have a lifeguard here at your
beach sometimes a guy moves into a house
with his childhood friends where they
play some group fortnight's sometimes
it's on the subway and sometimes it's
literally just the plot of domestic
girlfriend with even more fortnight but
some of the most common Johnnie's you'd
find are vanilla
some nice simple wholesome lovemaking
harem imagine if the protagonist of a
harem anime wasn't a complete dance who
is oblivious to social cues incest chota
Lali NTR basically if you take darling
in the Franks but remove the giant
robots and space and just leave the sad
cucking when you need your fat served
with a side of depression but I don't
know anyone who'd actually enjoy that
hold on a second
not to mention some of the most popular
character trope she finds which includes
childhood friends little sister big
sister milf hot housewife class
president elfs 500 year old demon
lollies cat girl schoolgirls and if you
think it sounds like I'm just listing a
bunch of popular anime tropes well
goddamn right witches sparks the age-old
debate of what came first the hentai or
the anime which is actually a trick
question because the correct answer is
the viewer also like anime hentai has to
deal with censorship but instead of the
bright white lights or literal black
spots we just get some pixelated action
a staple so ingrained in the medium is
cause many to speculate if everyone in
Japan is actually just born with
pixelated genitalia to everyone in other
countries this may be an annoying aspect
but to me there's a lot of hard work
that goes into this craft I mean can we
just take a moment to appreciate the
fact that it's someone's job to
correctly motion track all of the
genitalia movement in hentai to make
sure the pixels are perfectly
frame-by-frame synced with the animation
just think about it for a second the
someone's job thankfully this type of
censorship isn't as bad in hentai other
forms because if for whatever reason you
find yourself feeling like you're
useless just remember that the black
bars in dojin cheese actually think
they're doing their job speaking of
their Jin Chi these are the proverbial
manga of the hentai world and if you
think margaritas are proud when the
series they've been following is getting
an anime this is nothing compared to how
proud the Jin Xiu readers feel whenever
they watch a hentai and realise they've
already fapped to the source material
however the Jin cheese are more famous
for the scene of independent artists
being able to draw
fan fiction involving your favorite
anime characters and this is where their
true power lies because they can
actually shape your opinion of an anime
discovering anime cause your friends
talked about its how about discovering
anime because you've seen though ginchy
of it the gosh Akashi was a mediocre
anime franchise until you learned it was
producing s tier dojinshi material and
I'm actually convinced at this point
that fates grand order is really just an
extensive dojinshi series that happens
to have a corresponding mobile game of
course no medium is without its issues
and unfortunately hentai is no different
see while everyone is busy trying to
stop manmade climate change and
spreading awareness about the Amazon
rain forest fires US soldiers have been
fighting against the true epidemic that
threatens the safety of our world and
that is the invasion of fats ugly smelly
men standing at the centerpiece of every
head time where did they come from
what do they want from us who actually
enjoys this these are questions nobody
has been able to answer but no one on
the outside will ever know the true pain
of forgetting to check the tags before
indulging in what you think is a nice
wholesome story of two anime characters
enjoying some legal for tonight starring
a perfect thicker than a snicker peak
wifey material anime girl when suddenly
out of the corner the door opens and you
see you know I don't exactly see myself
as an atheist but there are times in
life I have to question my faith like if
God truly Israel then why does the ugly
bastard tag exist in hentai what higher
power would look down on the human
species and think to themselves you know
what they want to see a hot anime girl
getting railed by pot of greed but if
you're feeling in enough of a
self-loathing mood to click that ugly
bastard tag just remember the ugly
bastard law of proportionality where the
increasing hotness of an anime girl is
directly proportionate to the ugliness
fatness and smelliness of the bastard
railing her in fact this is a golden
rule that can be applied to all hentai
the more dark deranged and messed up
hentai the better the art and animation
it's a rule that is as consistent as a
laws of physics that govern our universe
if you see these tags on an episode
you're guaranteed to be treated to some
top-tier got like gourmet sakuga fest
made by some studio bones hentai
offshoot while those who want to enjoy
some nice innocent vanilla love story
gets some 90s berserk level animation
that looks like a moving slide show or
even worse it gets animated by queen bee
is like hentai artists are in a constant
game of not chicken with the viewer
where they're [__] daring you to do
something your dick would never forgive
him for and look I get that this is the
place where every fetish is catered for
but sometimes the guy just wants to
enjoy some high quality vanilla
guilt-free hentai alright so what was
the point of this video am I just trying
to abuse my subscriber count' in order
to create more degenerate so I don't
have to feel so weird about myself yeah
but also as much as II Sakai and Shonen
and crappy moto shows hentai is just as
much part of the medium of anime too we
all know the famous meme is called
hentai and it's art but sometimes it
really is you might be familiar with the
genre that's been popping up in anime
recently I can't believe it's not hentai
but what about this opposite genre when
you have hentai this good who needs
anime because there is some legitimately
great things to be found here
there are hentai out there that looks
better than most series a lot of famous
manga in fact have come from artists who
started with hentai retake is a dojinshi
series has given me a more satisfying
ending to Evangelion than End of
Evangelion in fact we already have an
even galleon of hentai fuga is an artist
who I get more emotionally invested in
their work than most anime I never
thought I could shed a tear to porn
until I read knows Oh Keanu and fate is
a hint our games so good than it is now
turned into a billion-dollar franchise
because see the best hem ties are the
ones that are so captivating you forget
the main reason you started reading it
in the first place because as we all
know he generates watch anime for the
plot buts real gentlemen watch hentai
for the plot thank you for coming to my
TED talk I'm gonna go watch some ugly
bastard hentai now it takes a real man
to
find your victims into the dirt and
decimate them completely you know to
make them grovel and then [__] on their
hopes and dreams you're so romantic
mister sorry oh absolutely
now get your panties off from the
[__] [__] hey guys hope you enjoyed
that video thank you very much this
month to Axl Cloris water supreme sayin
Nicholas Tatum Mike Altman sisters one
zero zero eight six and everyone else on
patreon for supporting me this month and
helping me to make a video about hentai
I couldn't have done it without you guys
as we all know the fall season of anime
starting soon and I will be doing my 4
season streams ok hold up for a second I
actually recorded this last week and I
was going to announce my fall season
stream right now but unfortunately
something's come up and unfortunately I
won't be doing a fall anime stream this
season I know I know I'm sorry I'm sorry
but I do have a legitimate reason for
that which I'm not sure I can announce
right now but let's say for the next
month I'm going to be very very busy
so yeah apologies for that guys anyway
that's it for me I've been Giga and
please stop watching ugly bastard
henselae I know there's least one of you
[__] that enjoy